so I'm seated on the left side which is
not the driver's side of the newest
Lotus EV they Maya this car is sick and
there's a lot of crazy features that I'm
going to put in my full autofocus video
but I wanted to just show you the
craziest one which is this screen in the
middle which already looks really good
is really impressive first of all it
runs Unreal Engine so this is a real
time twin of the car that I'm sitting in
that responds in real time now there's
no Android auto there's no apple carplay
this is again Lotus trying to convince
us that this is the way forward let me
know if you agree check this out this is
the window of the car I'm gonna put the
window down in actual real time and you
can see
the window actually goes up and down as
I do it in real life what about if I
just open the door
here I'll open the door
now the door on the car it opens
that's crazy I close it
it closes
Unreal Engine in a car who knew